[Musique]
ça l'aidera massa s'est pas trompé de
destination
bonjour à tous alors il ya quelques
jours j'ai essayé de partir en vacances
avec mes potes aux bahamas voilà et puis
en arrivant on a découvert sept à cette
pluie une sorte de tempêtes plus vieux
inattendue qui s'est abattue pile poil
sur les bahamas la semaine
tournier en fait c'est le décor des
caraïbes avec le temps de la bretagne
[Musique]
c'est juste catastrophes naturelles
content de vivre là bas faire part en
couille
y'a plus de saison puisqu'on à dire là
dessus que les commentaires l' écoute
j'apprends est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est une sorte de matelots et une sorte
de mousse à tribord tout avoue qu on
arrive et on vous le dire à tout le
monde qu'on était obama sur les réseaux
pour ça raconte et comme tout le monde
sauf qu'on n'arrivait pas trop assumer
que le toit était pouilles du coup
montrer nos vacances mais pas
complètement un montrer juste une partie
alors ici c'est ma chambre d'hôtel voilà
qu'une petite vue est plutôt sympa j'ai
déjà sacré c'est bon la bulle est en
train un autre jour c'est magnifique
chat papa tu vois cette carte postale et
bas ne correspond pas du tout à mes
vacances
un mois je suis carrément sous la flotte
geste embrasse ton [ __ ] fils qui
t'aime un max donc on est dans le
jacuzzi avec les potes et regardez là il
ya vraiment un mec tout cas tout habillé
dans le jacc postier es ce que vous avez
des éléments en forme de pluie c'est
pour un souvenir alors qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire comme activité lova quand il
pleut c'est pas c'est pas génial c'est
pas ouf
le voilier certes le problème wes pleut
je crois j'ai l'idée puissance 4
yes jusqu'au moment où j'ai eu une idée
et si on rentrait avec la météo bien si
on part en avant maintenant jo et puis
finalement on s'est mis à qui fait nos
vacances on a juste pris du plaisir et
profiter du cadeau qui la vie parce que
la vie est un cadeau un on n'est pas
souvent informées de ça mais c'est un
cadeau
personne contre toute attente alors
qu'il fait extrêmement pas froide est
très très évident il pleut énormément on
prend du plaisir à se baigner dans cette
piscine avec le tonnerre au dessus de la
tête
[Musique]
très très grosse ambiance sur la plage
alors on leur dit jamais assez bon c'est
bien mettre de la crème solaire et de la
biafine et à vous mettre souvent à
l'ombre
surtout quand vous êtes obama ça c est
pas mal c'est de vue on se regarde pas
les containers qui en dessous - parce
que là c'est moins bien
c'est marrant sur la danse de l'hôtel ce
n'était pas écrit calais ça et là bas
c'est le château le château des bons
débuts le risque quand même
on vient de remporter le jackpot on
vient de gagner une somme de nouveau
casino s'est emballée bâbord au magal et
de douceur
allez c'est cadeau
c'était un prince c'était tout tout tout
tout est ok ok alors coûté à derniers
jours aux bahamas que se passe-t-il le
temps est idéal 27 degrés soleil du coup
de chaleur aucun nuage est ce qu'on est
content là on est très très contents
et là je vous emmène dans la soute
forest c'est une forêt où les gens se
suicider je pense que je vais filmer à
un pendu à les dédicaces à logan paul
scheer m'attendais mais il ya un
problème la jda a cogné un beau cheval
de chevaux à mollau turquoise moga
ok votre séjour aux bahamas se terminer
ici on a tellement qui fait on est au
bout de l'île voilà ça m'a vraiment la
fin d'un séjour d'un plaisir entre amis
c'est vraiment énorme sens où va bientôt
énorme faits marquants de la vie abonnés
de la chaîne youtube et piqué sur la
cloche de recevoir les notifications
m
non